in der beringsee vor der küste alaskas
verschwindet eine erfahrene crew
die ermittler sind ratlos
plötzlich war das schiff einfach weg was
ist passiert wir hatten keine zeugen und
kein schiff die ursachenforschung
beginnt ein puzzleteil nach dem anderen
bis die katastrophe
rekapituliert werden kann
alles kommt zusammen zur gleichen zeit
am gleichen ort
ein fischerort steht unter schock wir
konnten es nicht fassen die eigene
sterblichkeit wird einem bewusst es
hätte jeden treffen können
[Musik]
das 30 meter lange fischerboot
destination durchkreuzt die eiskalte
beringsee nordwestliche richtung
[Musik]
kapitän steht am ruder wie so oft in den
letzten 23 jahren
er war ein erfahrener fischer und ein
kluger kopf er wusste wie es läuft
er war sicher und sorgfältig sein
kapitän wie man ihn sich wünscht
die schnee krabben saison hat begonnen
64 boote durchpflügen mit ihren korb
reisen das meer um möglichst viele der
lukrativen krustentiere zu fangen
für die crews bedeutet dass wochenlang
rosé und eiseskälte ein knochenjob
für rwe ist es die beste zeit des jahres
fand immer welche selbst in einer pfütze
wieder wollte nach seinem schiff
anheuern
er in einer guten saison konnte man
sechsstellig verdienen oder mann machte
keinen cent vorher weiß man es nie aber
das macht den job so romantisch
von das habe aus nimmt die destination
kurs auf die über 400 kilometer
entfernten krabben gründe im norden
[Musik]
verio grady kennt die destination fast
genauso lang wie der kapitän mittagszeit
gevas essen klingt gut
wer einmal kennengelernt hat wird ihnen
nie vergessen er war eine riesen
persönlichkeit
immer hilfsbereit immer für andere da
wenn man was nicht konnte brachte er es
einem bei
die anderen vier mitglieder sind
schiffsingenieur charts von joe ross
sowie die matrosen raymond wintzler der
export und kai ham egg
hinter ihnen liegt ein anstrengender
monat kabeljau jagt
die perfekte mischung aus jugend und
erfahrung die besten der besten richtig
hart arbeitende jungs
geliebten und tasten sich wie eine große
familie
mit diesem video beginnt unsere serie
über das leben auf dem schiff mein
bruder tarik ich bewunderte ihn er war
lebenslustig aktiv ein guter vater und
familienmensch
erzählt unseren begeisterten fans zu
hause was du hier machst
kaffee war ein witzbold er war klug und
der einzige der eine videokamera
bedienen konnte beim krabbenfang
brauchst du core preußen 320 kilo pures
glück
haben dauernd gefilmt und so getan als
wären wir filmstars
in jedem keller beute ist einer von
denen hier
mal ne sardinen oder heringe
unser köder geheimrezept so bringen wir
in alaska essen auf den tisch
jeder hatte seinen eigenen köder auf den
er schwor
wir sind da wo die karten sind das war's
für heute bis zur nächsten folge
an deckte destination es platz für 224
chor preisen in die drei großen fisch
behälter passen weitere 110 1000 kilo
hinein im vorderfuß befinden sich die
kombüse die schlafkabinen und der
steuerstaat
war eine streitaxt ein arbeitstier wir
fuhren gern mit dem chef
in den folgenden tagen lassen die männer
ihre chor preußen wieder und wieder zu
wasser
für mich ist die fischerei wie die jagd
auf wilde tiere so als wäre ich in der
serengeti und verfolgen werden die immer
weiter ziehen und irgendwo grasen
genauso folgen wir den graben schwärmen
sobald die männer fündig werden klingelt
es in der kasse man macht fett kohle das
ist echt cool doch in der beringsee gibt
es nichts geschenkt
wir haben tropenstürme aus asien die
hierher ziehen und kalt wetterfronten
aus dem norden da ist schlechtes wetter
garantiert
es ist eine wunderschöne hölle die
stürme fegen teils mit 80 kilometern pro
stunde über das meer und die wellen sind
zehn meter hoch
catalin stehst bist du hier richtig
während die destination nach norden
fährt verschlechtert sich das wetter in
der beringsee
was ziemlich krass da draußen die jungs
sollen die stapel checken ich will das
alles gesichert ist okay wird gemacht
hey jungs ziemliches chaos draußen lasst
uns die stapel sichern
durch den seglern verschieben sich die
reusen und die ketten können sich
lockern daher müssen wir die von zeit zu
zeit nachziehen so privat ein paar jungs
klettern dann hoch meistens tragen sie
rettungswesten und sich an die reusen
damit die nicht über bord gehen
sie haben die fanggründe fast erreicht
und werden schon bald mit der arbeit
beginnen
wenn sie die fischgründe erreichen also
nachts oder morgens lässt chef die jungs
meist schlafen damit alle fit sind
wenn's losgeht
die destination passiert die insel saint
george und erreicht kurz vor sechs uhr
morgens die nordwestspitze genannt
wenn man den passiert hat erreicht man
wieder das offene meer
dort gibt es kaum schutz das wetter kann
extremer werden das schlägt dort sehr
schnell um
die männer haben diese tue schon
mehrfach erfolgreich gemeistert doch
dieses mal ist es anders
um 6 uhr 15 empfängt die küstenwache ein
signal von der notruf baake der
destination ein zeichen dass der not
sender unter wasser geraten ist in der
regel heißt das dass das schiff gesunken
ist
niemand weiß ob sie im wasser treiben im
rettungsboot setzen oder ihre überlebens
anzüge tragen die retter der küstenwache
sind mehr als zwei stunden entfernt da
ist die nation destination ihr sprecht
server spray schiffe in der nähe
beteiligen sich an der suche
um 36 meldeten sie sich bei uns auf der
silver spray und baten die destination
über ukw an zu funken
kapitän will braut auf dem krabbeln
finger server spray reagiert sofort
destination hier spricht silva spray
bekommen
wir versuchten mehrfach funk kontakt
herzustellen
destination hier selber spray keine
antwort hier stimmt was nicht
destination destination her servers
bitte melden
kapitän braut weiß dass jede minute im
eiskalten wasser über leben und tod der
crew entscheiden kann
destination destination hessel was break
bitte kommen
der wettlauf gegen die zeit beginnt
verspricht
das flugzeug der küstenwache kanal 16
seit die destination ein notsignal
gefunkt hat sind fast vier stunden
vergangen
die flugzeuge der küstenwache hatten das
suchgebiet nördlich von san george
island erreicht und suchen das gebiet ab
auch kapitän will braucht der bereits
vor sonnenaufgang in dem seegebiet war
beteiligt sich an der suche nach der
vermissten gesucht
und suchst du suchst oft jemanden im
überlebensanzug im wasser zu finden oder
ein leuchtfeuer irgendwas
meine crew war im steuerhaus und draußen
auf dem achterdeck wir hielten die ganze
zeit ausschau und hofften eine
rettungsinsel oder irgendjemanden zu
sehen das ist schon seltsam wenn man
jemanden nicht findet er eigentlich
direkt vor einem sein müsste
dann entdeckten wrackteile und
einen rettungsring
eine welle erwischte ihn und drehte ihn
um wir konnten den namen lesen da stand
das wort destination
uns wurde klar dass hier was passiert
sein musste
[Musik]
der hubschrauber der küstenwache lotste
uns zu einigen trümmerteilen
wir entdeckten die note funke sie hing
an einer etwa 10 meter langen leine die
hat sich nicht von selbst da festgemacht
jemand hat sie sich genommen und ans
seil gebunden vielleicht um sich an ihr
festzuhalten
es war sehr real
das alles ist schon eine ganze weile her
aber immer wenn ich daran denke berührt
es mich was macht mich traurig wenn ich
an die denke die ertrunken sind
[Musik]
die suche läuft mehr als drei tage
ich wartete neben dem telefon auf den
anruf der küstenwache das war
unerträglich
ich bin derzeit um zehn jahre gealtert
der ganze stress und die sorge um die
freunde
noch tage später oft und betete ich dass
man ein rettungsboot finden würde
wir hatten hoffnung dass man sie findet
bevor es dunkel wird dass wir ein licht
sehen oder irgendwas wir spielten alle
szenarien durch aber nichts davon
bewahrheitete sich
ich kam nach hause war in meinen
sicheren vier wänden als ich davon hörte
so dicht an zu hause
der kapitän und seine fünfköpfige crew
sind tot es ist der schlimmste unfall
für laskas fischereiindustrie seit mehr
als zehn jahren
das bricht einem das herz wirklich so
eine tolle crew und so ein wunderbarer
kapitän wir waren total geschockt ich
betete dass sie alle in ihren kojen
lagen und schliefen dass sie nicht
ahnten was da auf sie zukommt
ich wollte mir nicht vorstellen dass
larry wusste dass er ertrinkt ich wollte
nicht dass er das weiß
[Musik]
ich habe meinen oder verloren das heißt
eine riesenlücke in mein leben
die krabbenfischer dort farbe beginnen
fragen zu stellen
wie konnte das schiff so plötzlich
sinken und könnte sich so etwas
wiederholen
die küstenwache leitet eine dringliche
untersuchung ein
scott müller leitet die ermittlungen in
der tat suchte nach antworten
sächsischer starben sechs familien sind
für immer gezeichnet
wie kann ich ihnen helfen müller spricht
mit gott will wird den
sicherheitsbeauftragten der küstenwache
erst seit 20 jahren für die region
zuständig wir halten alle zusammen jeder
kennt jeden privat roller vom fischfang
dies war die letzte hafen vor dem
auslaufen ihm kommt eine schlüsselrolle
bei den ermittlungen zu
ich erhoffe mir aufschluss über die
letzten tage der destination
ich konnte sehen wo sie trocken waren
köder oder treibstoff aufluden ich
konnte die leute fragen ob mit dem
schiff oder der crew etwas nicht in
ordnung war ich suchte nach puzzleteilen
um mir ein bild zu machen
hallo guten morgen sonntag dürfte ich
ihnen bei fragen stellen
das schärft die krude illusion lady half
uns bei den ermittlungen
kapitän dax erfurt wird zum zeitpunkt
des unglücks auf see und hatte vor dem
unglück vom kontakt mit captain hathaway
ich kannte ja schon ewig er war einer
der besten
war sichtlich erschüttert er war
möglicherweise der letzte mit dem chef
in jener nacht gesprochen hat
sie sprachen über strategien tauschen
informationen aus nichts ungewöhnliches
was fischer ebenso reden
eine sache gab es aber und zwar
habt ihr extra köder an bord jede menge
in saint-paul wurden die köder knapp
deswegen haben jeff eine extra ladung
auf wie viel mehr
das weiß ich nicht
[Musik]
es gab einen köder mangel in saint paul
also in der gegend in der sie fischen
wollten daher kaufte jeff zusätzliche
schilder in einem kühlhaus in dutch
harbor
wenige stunden bevor sich die
destination auf ihre letzte reise macht
werden die ersatzzüge an bord geladen
sie waren eine halbe stunde her zwischen
18 30 und 19 uhr
sprach mit dem kühlhaus manager er
bestätigte dass sie da waren und ein
paar tausend kilo kinder abholten
village stößt auf ein weiteres wichtiges
indiz
existiert ein video von der destination
im dock wir konnten also sehen wie sie
aussah nachdem sie fertig beladen war
es ist schon ein seltsames gefühl wenn
man ein video von einem schiff sieht das
wenige stunden später zu seiner letzten
reise aufbricht
die destination andockt hat sie bereits
eine große ladung köder in ihrem
kühlraum gelagert und auf deck sind 200
chor preußen gestapelt
gegen ende der videoaufzeichnung machen
die ermittler eine überraschende
entdeckung sie sehen dass der board kran
über 3000 kilogramm extra köder auf den
chor preußen stapelt
[Musik]
eine menge extra gewicht es ist nie gut
wenn man ein schiff zu hoch gelegt
schwere ladung sollten auf einem schiff
so flach und mittig wie möglich verstaut
werden
das feld nach oben gestapelte extra
gewicht verschiebt den schwerpunkt des
schiffs und verringert seine stabilität
bei wellengang die stabilität ist fast
immer thema wünsche für untergehen oder
kentern
gegen 19 uhr verlässt die destination
den hafen knapp 3000 kilometer wurden
oben auf den reifenstapeln verstaut hat
dieses zusatzgewicht die katastrophe
ausgelöst
die ermittler wollen es herausfinden
ziemlich viel gewicht obendrauf
genau das gegenteil dessen was wir sonst
zum thema stabilität sagen nicht in die
höhe laden
aber ist die destination so in see
gestochen
wir zogen durch das habe um zu erfahren
welche stationen die destination anfuhr
die ermittler finden heraus dass die
crew vor dem auslaufen noch einen stopp
einlegte
ich bin runter zu ihrem liegeplatz um zu
hören ob es was neues gibt und eine
runde zu plaudern
auch schon gehört dass du hier bist die
linda sechs jahre lang auf der
destination diese saison arbeitet er
jedoch auf einem anderen schiff
ich wollte meinen bruder sehen fragen
wie es ihm geht ob er was braucht
handschuhe oder regensachen mein kleiner
besorgter bruder nein danke ich hab was
ich brauche
wir quatschen eine runde von umarmte ich
ihn und wir verabschiedeten uns
es ist das letzte mal dass dylan sein
bruder und seine ehemaligen kollegen
sieht
er kann sich allerdings nicht daran
erinnern wo die köder zu dieser zeit
gelagert waren
wir fakten dylan ob jeff schon früher
die köder so hoch gestapelt hatte ein
oder zweimal sagte er eher selten ex
crew mitglied patrick ofner glaubt nicht
dass jeff so in see gestochen deren
das war bestimmt nur vorübergehend
einfach schnell auf die reusen packen
damit das nächste boot andocken und
seine vorräte aufladen kann
sie hatten die köder dann bestimmt
runtergeholt und decke sichert damit sie
auf see nicht hin und her rutschen
die ermittler werden die frage wo die
köder gelagert waren nicht abschließend
klären können
sie müssen nach anderen spuren suchen
zum team gehört auch der erfahrene
ermittler den gillette
wir wollten wissen warum die destination
in seenot gerät andere schiffe jedoch
nicht also trugen wir alle verfügbaren
beweise zusammen
laut wettervorhersage herrschte
nordostwind die ermittler sehen sich den
wetterbericht des unglückstags an
die beringsee ist rau es gibt schlechtes
wetter und richtig schlechtes wetter mit
fast zehn meter hohen wellen und
hurricane artigen winden
sehr extremes wetter
25 knoten wind und drei meter hohe
wellen ziemlich heftig aber nichts was
die jungs nicht schon kannten
die meteorologischen daten ergaben
nichts außergewöhnliches nichts was ein
kentern erklärt hätte
schauen wir uns mal dass es an es gibt
wieder ein wrack noch überlebende doch
die ermittler haben ein detailliertes
bewegungs protokoll des schiffs von der
gesamten reise
das automatische position systems
empfängt alle vom schiff gesendeten
daten via transponder und überträgt sie
in eine karte
so lassen sich alle geschwindigkeits und
kurswechsel der destination
nachvollziehen ebenso wie mögliche
probleme
sie verließen das aber am 9 kurz vor
mitternacht und fuhren richtung norden
zweimal verlangsamten sie das tempo und
änderten den kurs 14 minuten und hier
eine gute stunde
die tracking daten zeigen dass die
destination zwei mal das tempo drosselte
und in den wind drehte vielleicht
arbeiten an bord
das ja nicht ungewöhnlich man fährt aufs
meer hinaus und wird langsamer so dass
man an deck arbeiten kann vielleicht
hatten sie einen maschinenschaden oder
wasser drang ins schiff 1
dann sehen sie sich die letzten minuten
vor der katastrophe
die zurück
dies erkannten wir eine scharfe wende
nach steuerbord
um sechs uhr morgens fährt die
destination plötzlich eine scharfe
rechtskurve und rät sich anschließend um
256 grad
das boot fuhr weiter drehte sich aber um
die eigene achse ziemlich beunruhigend
wenn ein schiff sich so verhält
drei minuten später wird die notrufe
aktiviert dann verstummt das signal
letzter moment in diesem augenblick
verloren sechs menschen ihr leben
[Musik]
es bricht einem das herz die letzten
sekunden im hs zu sehen man denkt an die
crew und ihre familien
was ist da passiert
was auch immer es war es ging schnell
die rs daten machen den fall noch
rätselhaft warum drehte sich die
destination kurz vor dem kentern
ein mechanischer fehler
die ermittler treffen den schiffseigner
in seattle sie wollen mehr über die
geschichte der destination erfahren
es war sehr wichtig mit dem eigner zu
sprechen er hatte das boot gekauft flott
gemacht und den kapitän angeheuert er
war in allem involviert
hier haben wir alles
rechnungen belegen
wir wollten wissen ob das schiff eine
vorgeschichte hatte ob mechanische
probleme bekannt waren oder wie die
destination gewartet wurde
etwas für den ermittlern in den wartungs
berichten auf
sieht aus als wurde die steuerung
repariert ja stimmt letzten sommer
erfuhren dass das ruder einseitig
blockierte und die destination hatte
probleme mit der steuerung so dass das
schiff stark in eine richtung zog
genau wie die ermittler ist auf der
karte beobachteten kurz bevor die
destination st die steuerung kam
definitiv in betracht das boot drehte
hart nach steuerbord vielleicht gab es
ein problem mit dem ruder
es hatte früher schon probleme mit dem
ruder gegeben vielleicht jetzt wieder
ein steuerungs problem der grund für die
plötzliche kursänderung und führte das
zum kentern des schiffs
die ermittler wollen es genau wissen sie
suchen an den früheren bordmechaniker
der destination auf vielleicht kann er
hinweise geben können sie uns sagen was
da genau gemacht wurde der mann
berichtet von gelegentlichen problemen
mit der steuerung
das ruder wird hydraulisch gesteuert es
war ja auch weiß gott nicht mehr das
jüngste
wenn es blockiert geht das schiff scharf
in die eine oder andere richtung das
beeinträchtigt die stabilität und kann
zum kentern führen
sie reagiert nicht einen zwischenfall
dieser art gab es zuletzt ein jahr vor
der tragödie
wir haben alles auseinander gebaut
die mechaniker fanden kleinste partikel
im hydrauliksystem die die fehlfunktion
des ruders verursachten
die ruderanlage ist ein geschlossenes
system
wenn sie verschmutzt ist kann das
gravierende folgen haben wir mussten die
komplette steuerung ausbauen und neue
montieren
die steuerung des schiffs wurde komplett
überholt und repariert sie wurde
anschließend getestet und wie sich
zeigte funktionierte sie danach wieder
tadellos
das steuersystem versagt haben
möglich aber eher unwahrscheinlich es
war ja gerade erst grundlegend überholt
worden
die steuerung kommt nicht in betracht
doch wie bei der technische paar gemeint
zustand des schiffs zum zeitpunkt der
havarie danke gerne wir müssen uns
genauer ansehen was alles an dem schiff
gemacht wurde
die ermittler untersuchen die historie
des schiffs
wir wollten wissen ob es seit der
anschaffung veränderungen oder
modifizierungen am schiff gegeben hatte
die destination wurde 1981 gebaut elf
jahre später folgte ein umbau um das
schiff hoch seetauglich zu machen
die destination wurde breiter und länger
das schiff wurde um etwa fünf meter
verlängert und zudem verbreitert eine
massive stahlband wurde nachgerüstet um
das fordert vor wassereinbruch zu
schützen
der bub wurde abgerundet um die farbe
ruhiger und energieeffizienter zu machen
es ist immer problematisch wenn man an
ein schiff metallteile anbaut wie etwa
eine begründung oder eine stahlwand
die umbauten haben das schiff sehr viel
schwerer gemacht
wir wollten herausfinden ob diese
nachrüstungen die stabilität der schiff
ist beeinträchtigten nachrüstungen
müssen laut gesetz von der küstenwache
abgenommen werden
der eigner muss einen schiffbauingenieur
hinzuziehen der die veränderungen im
hinblick auf die stabilität des bootes
prüft
die entsprechende prüfung wird den
stabilitäts- buch des schiffs
eingetragen
das stabilitäts buch hilft dem kapitän
die beladung seines schiffs richtig zu
berechnen damit es stabil im wasser
liegt er weist dann wie die cordhosen
beladen werden müssen und wie viele er
an bord nehmen darf
es ist praktisch eine anleitung für den
kapitän wie er sein schiff stabil hält
beim blick in der stabilitäts- buchte
destination machen die ermittler eine
alarmierende entdeckung der
stabilitätsbericht ist mehr als 20 jahre
alt
das stabilitäts buch wurde 1993 angelegt
und niemals wirklich aktualisiert
das war lange vor den umbauten
[Musik]
die destination wurde in den letzten 20
jahren mehrfach grundlegend umgebaut
ohne dass es einen aktualisierten
stabilitätstest gegeben hätte
die ermittler gehen davon aus dass das
ungeprüfte schiffer lastig und
gefährlich instabil war doch das müssen
sie beweisen
wir mussten wissen was genau sie an bord
hatten
fünf monate nach dem untergang der
destination wird er nicht
identifiziertes wrack in der nähe der
unglückstelle entdeckt
die küstenwache macht sich sogleich zur
fundstelle auf los geht's und schickte
einen tauchroboter zum frack
das wrack lag zu tief für einen
tauchgang daher setzen wir den roboter
ein
unteroffizier einem harris schickt den
roboter 78 meter tief bis zum
meeresgrund
wir wollten die destination eindeutig
identifizieren wir wollten sehen wie
viele corp reusen und köder sie an bord
hatte um das gewicht des bootes zum
zeitpunkt des unglücks bestimmen zu
können
doch der tauchgang gestaltet sich
schwierig
es gab nicht nur eine
oberflächenströmung sondern auch eine
starke strömung unterhalb von 30 metern
der tauchroboter
wir seien sehr viele seile
[Musik]
und viele trümmerteile
wir steuerten über das schiff und sahen
den kiel da stand destination an der
bordwand
destination da ist sie
in einem solchen moment gehen einem
viele sachen durch den kopf wenn man
sieht dass ein schiff so einen
furchtbaren unfall hatte so dicht vor
der eigenen haustür was war da nur
passiert
fünfeinhalb monate nach der tragödie ist
das fragte destination endlich gefunden
für die ermittler ist es ein durchbruch
sie hoffen den fall nun endgültig lösen
zu können das fragt der destination wird
eingehend untersucht
[Musik]
wir wollten einige der möglichen
unglücksursachen ausschließen etwa einen
schaden am rumpf vielen loch oder eine
bruchstelle
sie suchen nach jedem noch so kleinen
wir haben uns das steuerhaus angesehen
was offen oder geschlossen wie sah es
hinaus in welcher position standen die
gashebel
die beweise nach denen sie suchen sind
zum greifen nah
doch in der starken strömung lässt sich
der tauchroboter nur schwer steuern
ich glaube wir müssen sie heben
das war frustrierend
wir wollten so viele informationen wie
möglich zusammen tragen dabei aber nicht
riskieren dass der tauchroboter sich
verhakt oder verloren geht
das bildmaterial war letztlich nicht gut
genug für unsere untersuchung doch als
sie die operation abbrechen wollen
machen sie eine entdeckung
das müssen corp reusen sein ich schau
mal nach eine einzelne reise liegt in
der nähe des wracks
sie zogen eine korb reise mit einem
großen haken nach oben so war die
mission zumindest kein kompletter
reinfall
hat sie die reuse messen und wiegen
machen sie eine überraschende entdeckung
anhand des stabilitäts buchs erwarteten
wir eine 3 117 kilo reise
doch die reuse wiegt 300 81 kilogramm
das sind 64 kilo märz im stabilitäts
buch empfohlen
wir waren erstaunt wie schwer sie war
auf ihrer letzten reise hatte die
destination 200 dieser chor preisen an
bord
tonnenweise extra gewicht wir fanden
heraus dass sich die reusen seit den
1990 er jahren enorm verändert hatten
heute sind sie viel schwerer wenn man
das bei der berechnung der stabilitäts-
werte nicht berücksichtigt hat man ein
problem
die cordhosen der destination lagen 5
tonnen über dem zulässigen wert
war das dem kapitän unter dem
bootseigner bekannt wir konnten nur
raten es ist ein weiteres puzzleteil in
dem verzwickten fall da war der
abgerundete bug ein neuer stahl aufbau
und dazu noch das übergewicht
jedes für sich genommen ist nicht
signifikant doch in der summe hat es
gravierende folgen für die stabilität
des schiffs
die ermittler gehen davon aus dass die
destination gefährlich top last ich war
doch das boot war schon mehrfach mit
diesem gewicht in see gestochen was war
anders in der nacht des unglücks
wir fragten die kollegen der anderen
behörden
sie kontaktieren michael k den leitenden
ermittler der nationalen behörde für
transportsicherheit
codes ntsb auch erst mit dem fall
befasst
bei größeren schiffsunfällen sind sowohl
das ntsb als auch die küstenwache
involviert
wir führen eigene ermittlungen durch
kooperieren aber bei der
zusammenstellung und auswertung der
erkenntnisse
bildung ist eine der größten gefahren
auf der beringsee
eine unserer hypothesen war vereisung
wenn ein schiff während der fahrt
plötzlich verschwindet
leute das auf einen schnellen
stabilitäts verlust hin
dieser kann wiederum folge einer hohen
gewichts aufnahme an bord sein und eis
käme dafür als ursache in frage
wenn die lufttemperatur unter den
gefrierpunkt sinkt gefrieren tröpfchen
der kalten ozean giftstoff der schiffs
oberfläche im laufe der zeit wächst die
eisschicht immer weiter an
wenn sich das schiff durch die wellen
arbeit sprit durch die gischt viel
wasser an bord und bedeckte alles ja ich
rückkauf schnell hat man dann eis auf
der reling auf den decks und auf den
häusern
wenige stunden vor dem untergang gab der
nationale wetterdienst in ein college
eine ice warnung für die region heraus
unsere modelle können eisbildung
vorhersagen jedoch nicht wie stark diese
letztlich war
die ermittler holen sich hilfe bei
experten der memorial universität in
neufundland
dr de haan ist experte für
strömungsmechanik sein spezialgebiet ist
die vereisung von gst
ich schicke euch rüber
es ging darum die mögliche eismenge zu
berechnen die sich auf dem schiff
eingesammelt haben könnte die heinis
modell berücksichtigt parameter wie wind
temperatur
salzkonzentration und wellen höher
außerdem die bauart und die
materialzusammensetzung des schiffs die
beladung und die windrichtung am ende
hätte dann die vereisung seite des
schiffs wir berechnen die vereisung für
jede einzelne phase der fahrt
anhand der route die das schiff genommen
hatte konnten sie nachvollziehen wie
viel eis ich innerhalb von 15 minuten
jeweils gebildet hatte
mit hilfe der er es daten berechnet dh
nie wie stark die vereisung des bootes
tatsächlich gewesen sein muss
im ersten abschnitt der passage war
alles in ordnung
in den letzten stunden der destination
nahm die eisbildung spürbar zu
der wind verstärkte die vereisung ebenso
wie die temperatur und auch die bewegung
des schiffes selbst
das eis sammelt sich vor allem auf den
korb reusen
wegen ihre spezifischen struktur bildet
sich eis nicht nur außen an den rosen
sondern auch in ihrem inneren
ring mehr werden die reusen stapel oft
eiswürfel behälter genannt
als das signal verschwunden war muss die
eisbildung extrem stark gewesen sein
nach meinen berechnungen betrug die
eislast der destination zu diesem
zeitpunkt zwischen 92 und
150 tonnen
dass es deutlich mehr gewicht als bei
auslaufen des schiffes und es türmt sich
in die höhe so dass der schwerpunkt sich
nach oben verlagert
mit so viel gewicht kann sie in
sekundenschnelle kentern die ermittler
glauben dass die vereisung der ohnehin
schon überladenen destination den rest
gab
vermutlich wurde das schiff unter die
wasseroberfläche gedrückt und kennt
hatte
wave sie froren ein und kennt hatten
so schnell
war das ist furchtbar
die nächste graben saison steht vor der
tür und die ermittler fürchten dass auch
andere schiffe der schicksal der
destination erleiden könnten sie müssen
gewahrt werden bevor es zu spät ist
nein keine vereisung
in der zaber informiert wurde die
kapitäne über die gefahren der vereisung
er zeigt ihnen dass ihre ausrüstung
möglicherweise schwerer ist sie glauben
weiß die besatzung auf den fischerbooten
eigentlich wie schwer ihr material an
bord ist wir besorgten uns einige
schwerlastwagen und machten
stichprobenartige kontrollen der reisen
auf den schiffen
robert vergleicht das tatsächliche
gewicht mit den angaben in den
stabilitäts- büchern der schiffe
das gewicht der reußen überstieg in fast
allen fällen die vorgegebenen
stabilitäts werte
teilweise zehntausende kilo über dem was
ein schiff tragen kann
wir konfrontierten die kapitäne mit
einigen gewichtsangaben und die waren
überrascht wie schwer die reusen
tatsächlich waren
das schicksal der destination hat die
fischer in alaska aufgerüttelt
allen wurde die eigene sterblichkeit
bewusst sein was jeff geschah hätte
jeden von ihnen treffen können
wir nahmen daraufhin weniger corp reusen
an bord und wurden insgesamt
vorsichtiger die küstenwache
kontrolliert häufiger und wir sagen der
jüngeren generation vergesst nicht was
da draußen passieren kann
die küstenwache und das ntsb liegen ihre
abschlussberichte zum untergang der
destination vor beide beschreiben die
tragischen umstände unter denen sie sagt
ein umgebaute schiff bei dem niemals
stabilitätskontrollen gemacht wurden
zusätzliche köder und cordhosen die
schwere waren als erwartet
200 zusätzlich zum tatsächlichen gewicht
das war zu viel für das schiff und
schließlich die extreme vereisung die
das überladene schiff zum kippen brachte
alles kommt zusammen zur gleichen zeit
am gleichen ort
die küstenwache empfiehlt mittlerweile
exaktere stabilitätstests für
fischerboote
eine der wichtigsten
sicherheitsmaßnahmen ist die prüfung des
tatsächlichen gewichts der korb reisen
an bord
der stabilitätsbericht muss akkurat
geführt und ständig aktualisiert werden
das ntsb waren vor den gefahren durch
vereisung an bord
die enthält das ntsb gab eine
sicherheitswarnung heraus es hieß achtet
auf die eisbildung entfernt das eis an
bord
letztlich können wir nur hoffen dass die
leute auf uns hören dass sie auf die
risiken achten und sich bewusst sind
dass ihnen das gleiche passieren kann
[Musik]
larry und ich hatten beide diese
verbindung zum wasser
ich habe einen brunnen gebaut
wenn ich dorthin gehe sehe ich ihn
und ich habe ein schiff soll als
geländer
ich kann es berühren und mich durch
strömt eine energie
er war immer fröhlich und lächelte
ich fuhr immer gerne mit der destination
raus zum krabbeln fischen mit chef larry
und die crew das war immer ein spaß sie
hatten das herz am rechten fleck und
konnten hart arbeiten das war eine feine
kerle die einfach nur ihre familien
durch bringen wollten
all das hätte verhindert werden können
davon bin ich überzeugt
ich hoffe dass jemand der neu ins
geschäft einsteigt sich das anschaut und
daraus lernt
dann wären sie nicht umsonst gestorben